okay here we are hi everybody we're back
on the air Zoey should food ethics be
taught in school alongside nutrition oh
that's an interesting question food
ethics like I would think that that's
like against factory farming is what I
would teach in school yeah I mean I
think that would be great I think the
more we can talk about food and and how
to enter the conversation right now we
don't talk about food really at all your
kids in school yet my two year olds in
preschool because you know you're gonna
have to look at what they give him for
lunch in school I better lunch I'd like
in schools don't they I'll pack her
lunch she likes she likes carrot but not
broccoli in the garden in the garden as
long as she picks it can I make her go
out and pick it impact the garden a
whole garden in the back Rick Wilson
why do religious fundamentalists give
Trump a pass on behavior that they
otherwise condemn what's in the book of
poontang and it says
thou shalt allow the Donald to [ __ ] porn
stars yes let him get away with it it's
no it's just I'd say it's a imagine a
giant Mount Everest size pile of
hypocritical [ __ ] and that's where
they are on the peak of that may help
forgotten that word poontang there was a
shrine poontang shrine is there a lack
of media attention on how the ongoing
Russian BOTS social media desks will
impact our midterm elections heck yes
right that's the thing that you know if
you're gonna shut down the government
again how about the fact that to get the
last one they're not fighting the
ongoing war that's happening now to be
fair I think there's been a big change
this week one of Rose really fine
colleagues congressman shift from
supported by our senators senator
Feinstein wrote a letter to the big
three to really to Facebook and and
Twitter saying you have got to do
something about the ongoing Russian
manipulation because there was a thing
relative to this you know the Devin
Nunez conspiracy and the reality is that
that this is a huge issue I mean we have
to recognize that there is a structural
problem in our democracy in that we have
a lot of people who believe things that
are demonstrably not true roughly a
third of the population roughly 25% on
the right and there's more on the right
than on the left simply because Fox News
was out there for a long time creating
its own filter bubbles and so when the
Russians came in it was just a lot
easier to create disarray by focusing on
the right than it was on the left but
they're all the people who you know the
anti-vaxxers and people believed in
contrails and all that stuff so it's not
like there aren't any but it on the left
there on both sides and when people are
in that state of mind if they're like
people or BOTS who act like like people
who say oh by the way you should also
believe this you're going to believe
those people it's like a cult and we
need Facebook to contact every person
touched in 2016 by Russian interference
and explain
hey you're an American this was done to
our country by officers austell contact
every single person no it's actually
they have the email address for every
single one of those people they know
every single time they were touched they
have massive databases of all this stuff
and fortunately we have members of
Congress and Row is one of them who
understand that these issues are not
about left and right even if you like
the outcome of the last election you're
not gonna like the next one row do you
think you're you've no PAC caucus will
grow in the coming years we'll tell us
what it is for it no pet caucus just
means you don't take any money from
corporate PACs or lobbyists like Bernie
did there's seven of us in Congress who
have then I'll tell you why it's gonna
grow because when you have a Congress
that isn't acting on policies that 84
percent of the American supporters are
gamers or isn't acting on Medicare for
all which has 80 percent support or is
acting to repeal net neutrality when net
neutrality is 90 percent support
something is wrong yes and what's wrong
and yet Trump didn't have nearly didn't
spend nearly the money Hillary did
anyone know and Roger has insights on
partly it's partly why got an income
expenditure from yeah yeah but it's not
all about money
in fact sometimes money can work against
you you know Hillary bought a million
ads people get sick of those ads Trump
was smart he didn't advertise till the
end yeah you know people see the same
hat every day for two months in those
markets we don't get it here in
California because it's a it's a done
deal we don't we don't see ads we're not
in play but you know in in Illinois or
wherever the the battleground states are
you've seen them all the time you come
to hate that person they're just the
edge plays too much but a presidential
race is a little bit different because
you get to come on things like Bill
Maher and other things everyone knows
who you are when you're looking running
for Congress and no one knows who you
are I mean probably no one knew who I
was I came on this show no you know you
got to raise money and the problem is
that when you raise money you you're
beholden to those interests so it's a
huge issue okay is the fact that
liberals
vo Michelle aren't willing to demonize
right-wing media to the extent the right
does with the media one of the reasons
they lose the messaging war basically
you have the right has waged this
systematic assault right on the very
idea that there can I mean it's kind of
postmodern right they've waged this
assault on the idea that there can be
objective truth that you can believe
anything you see in the quote-unquote
mainstream media right they haven't
demonized the the left-wing media
they've demonized whatever knowing
whatever use and whatever used to
provide a kind of common source of
information and a common source war on
knowing things right and they don't want
us I don't know that it really would
help for liberals to go out and say that
you know Sean Hannity so I mean everyone
should say Sean Hannity sucks but it
doesn't really I think it would I think
it would actually reinforce the this
sense of of persecution and of
inferiority that drove a lot of lesser
educated Republican voters into the arms
of Fox and Rush Limbaugh they were told
you're smart to you know you but that's
the end that's the catch-22 you can't
say you're stupid right and then they
keep acting stupid yeah you know they're
not stupid except for all the behaviors
and beliefs
[Applause]
you